can we ask you about the outfit custom
couture
it's supposed to be subtle like me very
discreet
yes unclear the messaging no we dig here
though your outfit earlier is there some
kind of Kensington Palace not in that
can you tell me that okay so the outfit
was made the garment the garment was
made by Giles Deacon and he made that
fabric based on like I think it's a
Kensington Palace you know pillar or
something like that you know you're a
fan of the Royals how do you feel about
Harry and Megan maybe spending more time
in America we might get this out like
that you know he married a black girl
she was like we don't need that money
I've been here before sever work for
dick I love it she took him right on
with her I love her for it
she's a stylist she's everything to me I
love her um can we also ask you Brad
Pitt won his first big acting Oscar ever
how do you feel about the awards season
Brad's having he's like rocking the long
hair just living his life he's been here
forever he deserves it he's worked hard
congratulation Oh winning are you gonna
go in and celebrate without I'm trying
to get in there we just want to talk to
you about everything you do Billy I'm
sorry I'm trying to get in to see Sir
Elton John thank you you to walk out
Billy all of that bird
[Music]